tonight CNN is hosting Donald Trump in a
town hall that we have to absolutely
watch and probably make fun of now I
don't know that we're gonna make fun of
trump we'll probably make fun of the
questions and then probably answer them
or actually ask better questions but
we're going to be covering this and
commenting on CNN's town hall with
Donald Trump I think it's very important
to break down fact check and call out
any lies and there is some news the
reason we're starting a few minutes
early today is because they are going to
be doing the town hall at 8 pm unlike a
trump speech this one will probably be
on time well maybe not but more likely
to be on time considering it's it's CNN
scheduling and not not Trump's but I do
want to give a shout out to some news
stories juror 77 ah yes I'm in the news
once again first it was because
apparently some guy uh a horrible man
ran a a Russian social media account
where he posted clips from one episode
of our show which constitutes a fan I
suppose then we get this other juror in
the E Gene Carroll Story the rape trial
for Trump who appear currently watched
four episodes of the show as well and
they said that constitutes him being a
fan and for that he should be
disqualified from the jury
they also called me an extremist a
conspiracy theorist and all the other
nonsense but I do think it's fascinating
that they would go that far you've
watched a show a couple times kick him
off the jury that's how you know they're
an occult because I I don't see
conservatives or the right or decided
liberals doing anything like that or any
sane jury how often do you hear of of a
jury any side plaintiff defendant
whatever being like this guy watched
four episodes of Rachel Maddow they
should be removed from the trial that's
how insane these people are but I don't
give a shout to that story so definitely
uh shouting that one out then we got uh
some news as it pertains to Bud Light
their sales are down even more this week
now according to Nielsen 21 down last
week 23 percent down this week and we're
still lagging by by about two weeks of
data so I can only imagine the next
weeks are going to get worse because
it's becoming more than just a boycott
it has become toxic just people who
don't even know what's going on don't
want to be Associated and according to
Fox News Dylan Mulvaney says they have
trouble sleeping at night over this so
we'll talk about all that before we get
started friends head over to
castbrew.com
the show is sponsored by cast Brew
Coffee our new coffee brand and coffee
shop currently being constructed if you
want to support our work pick up your
coffee at casper.com get your rise with
Roberto Jr breakfast Blend or your
Appalachian nights robust dark blend we
also have French roast and Colombian
available and you can subscribe so that
the coffee is automatically delivered to
you every two weeks or one uh once a
month so again Casper coffee is our
company we're sponsoring ourselves thank
you all for your support head over to
timcast.com become a member by clicking
join us we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up for all of you
it's going to be a whole lot of fun
tonight after we wrap up this town hall
because we do have a lot of news that
we're probably not going to be able to
get into so smash the like button share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more and to comment humorously on the
town hall is carpe dongtum
hello who are you what do you do well uh
um I'm a meme maker I make the funnies
on on the internet uh I was uh banned
from Twitter for a couple years so that
was really fun I got sued over a meme
that was really fun wow
um
men's president once oh that's cool yeah
you make a bunch of funny memes and they
don't like you for it they really really
don't yeah
CNN really doesn't like me
um see let's see Daily Beast I I think
it's pretty much all of them I think
that's
was just right on but did you get anyone
disqualified from a jury
uh I didn't either so okay no I did I
did get a guy thrown out of his school
board
his school board
uh because he shared one of my memes oh
okay that was a couple years ago all
right there we go all right yeah well
this should be fun yeah well uh we got a
few we got about a minute going we got
Ben Stewart hanging out no Sheamus how's
it going everybody uh Ben
josephstewart.com a documentary
filmmaker and um pretty soon I have the
film with uh Harrison Schultz called
game of money that's going to be coming
up on Tim cast so that's gonna be fun
right on
I'm a writer for timcast.com
and I am search.com I'm ready for uh
This Town Hall when you are yeah we're
just we're just waiting we have about a
minute until the town hall starts we've
got uh CNN playing it matters against
him how does he deal with this latest
the legal I really I really don't want
to hear what these people have to say
right now so uh someone's walking on
stage uh so I certainly don't think
he'll change his tune on it but I can't
imagine it yeah I'm sorry I'm just going
to mute that until they actually start
getting ready because I don't need to
hear from those people you know I I
don't want to hear what CNN has to say
but uh without the other big story as I
suppose we're waiting uh for the town
hall to start was that Donald Trump was
found liable in that rape truck and that
rape trial I guess and the crazy thing
is we talked about this last night one
of the jurors apparently was a fan of
the show and he still they were
unanimous they unanimously found that
Trump was liable for sexual abuse of
this woman with what evidence zero zero
zero evidence she came out and said like
this one time this thing happened and
they're like wow Trump better pay her
five million dollars yeah 30 year old
bruises you know 30 year old bruises or
something no she didn't that's that's a
joke I'm making she still had him for 30
years you know there's no there's no
evidence there's nothing there do you
know how they can even do that how they
can find somebody liable for
a crime that they can't even prove
happened there's no crime the last year
in New York passed a law saying that
people who are assaulted can sue their
the people who assaulted them forever or
something like that and apparently they
went on CNN so like we helped get this
law passed so they helped make a law
that says they can sue a guy this is why
I'm saying Trump's going to be convicted
of uh of the the the the tax fraud or
whatever they're calling it improper
business filings they're going to
convict him it's going to be unanimous
do you know when they got that law
passed a year ago interesting I wonder
if they had this brewing for that long
oh yeah yeah of course probably passed
the law to bring this case that's what
I'm saying I mean I think they said that
didn't they that they helped get the law
passed that allow them to bring this
case and then you get a jury in New York
unanimously says Trump is liable that's
why I'm like people are saying you got
to get this guy in the shot I'm like
this anti-trump guy who thinks Trump's
responsible than 30 years ago really yo
he said he watched this four episodes of
the show he didn't say that he was a big
fan of it I mean I'd love to talk to him
is it what is CNN doing are they getting
ready for this here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
lower the volume on this it's so stupid
just mute it I can destroy it down
you actually need to be able to mute it
periodically yeah
is here as he embarks on a
campaigns he's the first former
president in more than a century to seek
a return to the White House she's
currently leading who's even doing the
moderation
Caitlyn just yesterday he was filmed
liable for sexual abuse Don lemon's not
doing it no questions at the table no he
doesn't work at CNN anymore
I didn't know our audience is made up of
Republicans and Undeclared Elon Musk
offered Don Lemon New Hampshire to do
his show on Twitter no joke seriously he
wants to question the former president
directly these voters
will help decide before President Trump
we'll get a second what do we think is
President Joe Biden is Trump going to be
as crazy as ever or is it going to be
really toned down
Donald Trump I think he's gonna probably
tone himself down he may make a few
remarks here because he's dying he's
looking presidential oh one side
standing ovation
cut that power tie on
so for those that are listening we'll
we'll be reading your super chats
periodically throughout the show
where they're most relevant
did you notice he doesn't have an X
where he has to walk thank you for your
time
around here a lot of Voters uh with a
lot of questions about what
would be 24
or term would look like what another
Trump term would look like we'll get to
the voters shortly but your polls show
that you are dominating the Republican
race right now but you were also under
active federal investigation for trying
to overturn the 2020 election results
your first term ended with the deadly
riot at the Capitol and you still have
not publicly acknowledge yeah
why should Americans put you back in the
White House because we did fantastically
we got 12 million more votes than we had
in as you know in 2016. I actually say
we did far better in that election got
the most uh that anybody's ever gotten
as a city president of the United States
uh I think that when you look at it that
result and also look at what happened
during that election unless you're a
very stupid person you see what happens
a lot of the people in this audience and
probably maybe a couple that don't but
most people understand what happened
that was a rigged election and it's a
shame that we had to go through it was
very bad for our country
no and they saw exactly what everyone
else the issue is what does it means
we're talking about Universal mail-in
voting 16 point difference uh if you
look at the FBI president if you look at
the FBI and uh Twitter they call it
Twitter files you see that's what he's
talking about you look at Mr President
back to what you just said if you're
talking about big tax election it was
not a stolen election you and your
orders more than 60 court cases on the
election it's been nearly two and a half
years can you publicly acknowledge that
you did lose the 2020 election let me
just go on
camera on government cameras where they
were stuffing ballot boxes so with all
of that I think it's a shame that what
happened I think it's a very sad thing
for our country no I think Trump is
gone to our country our country has gone
to Hell our borders are bad our military
has been bad you look at the taxes you
look at inflation what's happened to
inflation it's just destroying our
country we've really become in many ways
a third world country and it's very sad
what's happened in this Administration
and it's uh something that we'll turn
around on day one we're energy
independent now energy is at a level
that we've never had to pay before we
nobody can afford to continue to pay
what's happening with energy but we were
energy independent we were getting out
of Afghanistan with strength and with
dignity and instead we got would look
like fools probably the most
embarrassing moment in the history of
our country we have a lot of questions
about the economy and foreign
those claims about fraudulent ballots we
want to give you a chance tonight who
Republican officials in Georgia and
every single state there is no your own
election officials Mr President so we
wanted to be afraid to take on the issue
but we have a big problem in this
country we have a chance we have
elections that were horrible if you look
at what happened in Pennsylvania
Philadelphia if you look at what
happened in Detroit Michigan if you look
at what happens
it's frustrating because it's just three
years old people go into 28 different
voting vote
can't stop you there because he'd look
better if he just stayed on top
officials testified to that and have
said that Republicans and the issue is
the structural changes Democrats made
that gave them advantages
nursing homes
Independence here in New Hampshire as
you know yeah I don't think him talking
about what's your question for the
president
Trump welcome back to New Hampshire I
mean we're the only ones watching this
uh yeah polarizing talk of election
fraud during your run for president will
I suspend excuse me what will you
suspend polarizing talk of election
fraud during your run for president yeah
unless I see election fraud if I say
election
we should have one day elections we
should have paper ballots he's right
about that we should have it one day
voting IDs absolutely it's going to be
very straight up because if it's going
to be straight up we're going to win the
election so you will suspend talk to his
question about the 2020 election on the
campaign I guess so we're going to just
win we're at a point now we're getting
so close let's just win it again and
straighten out our country one other
question on this
they always want to force them in the
same yes or no in the past you once
suggested terminating the com the
Constitution do you stand by those
comments I don't know you were able to
do certain this I'm not talking about
terminating the Constitution I'm talking
about cherishing the Constitution the
Constitution says it was supposed to
have legal and well maintained and well
looked at elections and we didn't have
that I cherish our constitution but we
have to live up to the Constitution we
weren't living up to the Constitution I
would just say there's no evidence of
that election fraud you did once tweets
they're baiting him and he's falling
right for it I'm glad you say that but
he can't knock it off
he can say that's so old are you
seriously talking about that you sound
silly let's talk about important topics
right now
they know this hurts him in the polls
with moderate honest elections in our
country we have open borders there we go
yeah
he needs to Pivot to a question of the
borders yeah I mean I liked his
Afghanistan we have open borders look at
what's happening on our Southern border
millions and millions of people are
coming here they're being released from
prisons they're being released from
mental institutions and we have millions
of people pouring into our country and
now they're getting rid of title 42
which I put on which kept people out
that were sick and Mr President we have
a lot of questions about immigration to
get to tonight obviously that's a big
topic
expected to happen tomorrow but I want
to talk about the influence you have
over your voters it's very clear that
you are very influential over them you
have a lot of impact I've been to many
of your rallies and seen it up close
which raised a lot of questions about
the influence that we saw that you had
on them on January 6. this is the whole
plan for the town hall do you have any
regrets about your actions on January
6th
well you know uh January 6 was the
weekend we go back to it but January 6
had to do with the fact that hundreds of
thousands of people and you don't see
the pictures very often a lot of the
people here probably were there January
6th it was the largest crowd I've ever
spoken to that was prior to the walk
down to the Capitol Building I don't
think and I've spoken to hundreds of
thousands of people I've never spoken to
a crowd as large as this and that was
because they thought the election was
rigged and they were there proud they
were there with love in their heart that
was an unbelievable and it was a
beautiful day and what I was asked to do
I wasn't involved in it very much I was
asked to come in would I make a speech I
made a speech I said walk peacefully and
patriotically you know many different
things in fact I brought a list of
things I don't want to bore the audience
but we can go sentence after sentence
after sentence of things I said and
things I put out they're playing the
problems was that Nancy Pelosi crazy
Nancy as I affect gently called crazy
Nancy Pelosi and the mayor of Washington
were in charge as you know of security
I'm not sure what he's supposed to do
now because they're going to just keep
hitting him and he can keep coming from
them
soldiers will give you a National Guard
and I think this is a good thing and
they turned me down
at the time
Trump needs to talk about the economy
immigration immigration immigration
right now Miller wrote a book and he's a
fantastic guy and he was ready to go I
met the producer
January 6 election January 6 election
knock him down in the polls they'll hurt
Trump I don't like the look Nancy Pelosi
said oh we don't like that they haven't
said the high words I offered them ten
thousand but he really should have said
like very succinct talking points
and soldiers if they would have taken
five years
to see that they turned it down and if
you look at the Inspector General report
he says they turned it down they made a
terrible mistake well Chris Miller was
your acting defense secretary he says
you never gave this response isn't isn't
it terrible
but you said you weren't entirely you
did tell your supporters to come to
Washington you tweeted about it about
that speech that happened on the rally
in my life when they went to the Capitol
and they were breaking into the capital
smashing Windows injuring police
officers why did you why did it take you
three hours to tell them to go home I
don't believe it did oh let me pull it
out
let me pull it out I have to pull it out
so if you look at
on January 5th the day before I said
please support our Capitol Police and
law enforcement they are truly on the
side of our country stay peaceful stay
peaceful this was the day before and
this was in the form of Twitter now use
truth truth social I think it's far
superior okay
if you look January 6 at 2 before 2 30.
I am asking for everyone at the U.S
Capitol to remain peaceful this is right
after as it was happening but what
happened completely right they took it
down I don't know why I think they took
it down because it was so good they
didn't like it
and we didn't know until I got it back
because now I have 90 million people
waiting for me to go back but I'm unsure
that I'm staying on Truth Listen I am
asking for everyone at the U.S Capitol
to remain peaceful no violation that we
want no violation we want no violence
remember we are the party of Law and
Order respect the law and our great
remember that 20 minutes thank you that
was at 2 30.
you didn't report that you know why
because it was we did report it was
taken down or was it but when it was
clear to you that they were not being
peaceful you saw them rushing the
capitol breaking Windows they were
hitting officers with flagpoles tasing
them beating them up when it was clear
they weren't being peaceful why did you
wait three hours to tell them you didn't
leave the capital they listened to you
like no one else you know that they do I
agree with that it wasn't reality
I assumed they were able to do their
you couldn't get internet no we have to
have peace so we have to have Law and
Order we have to respect our great
people of Law and Order we love the
people we can't play into the hands of
things
and you know to this day it hasn't been
put up and the reason Trump was still
speaking on stage so conclusive that all
of this nonsense
that he was speaking when it happened or
just wiped away with this one and
they've never put it back up and that's
not what they did that's when the
barricades were broken through when
Northeast barricades are breached at 1
57 PM they breached the capital at 2 p.m
it means if he made that statement at 2
30 that was right away Minnesota
actually a little bit before that right
over 140 officers were injured that day
and a person named Ashley Babbitt was
killed yes you know what she was killed
and she shouldn't have been killed and
that Thug that killed her there was no
reason to shoot her they're going to hit
him Blank Range cold Blank Range they
shot her
and she was a good person she was a
patron there was no reason there was no
reason and
he went on television to brag about the
fact that he killed her that the officer
was not bragging about the fact that he
killed her but one person who was at the
Capitol that day as you know was your
vice president Mike Pence who says that
you endangered his life on that day I
don't think he was in any danger Mr
President do you feel that you owe him
an apology no because he did something
wrong the votes back to the state
legislatures and I think we would have
had a difference we're 16 minutes
annually we're still on January 6th um
because it's interesting let's keep it
interesting right and he is better she's
a very fine man he's a very nice man he
made a mistake his lawyer said you
cannot move I call them the human
conveyor belt I said even if the votes
you mean talk to his lawyer even if the
votes are absolutely fraudulent he can't
say yes sir he can't bet and the
Democrats played it and the Rhinos
played it and then the election was over
they told him he couldn't do it and Mike
said to me I can't do it the lawyers
told me you can't do it they can't do it
but the lawyers were wrong because right
after the election they all met the
rhinos and the Democrats and they worked
out a plan to make sure that future vice
presidents don't do what I said you
could do that's not what happened you're
referring to the Electoral account act
I've read I've read that there is there
is no Authority no legal experts
including Republican legal experts say
that he does is this a town hall line
I think it's a debate that you can't do
it they didn't change the law they
strengthened the law we've got one
question so far
they uh convinced him he didn't and it
was a horrible thing for our country if
you would have sent those votes back to
Georgia Pennsylvania and others rights
Wisconsin which if you look at this they
didn't try to pass along admitted now
that the election
to take away their powers after a minute
states
are wrong I'm sorry my bad I didn't
realize remember what I said
it pretty much you admitted what I said
was right they said he didn't have the
right to do it
by the end of it but I want to move on
the buyer he's a retired attorney
legal votes were cast in Wisconsin and
if you look in Milwaukee Wisconsin they
had so many legal illegal votes they
didn't even know what to do with them
you're absolutely Mr President there
weren't any fraudulent votes in
Wisconsin I do want to get to the
audience so we have questions for you
from the audience
Bill Barr said there were some obviously
served in Republicans he volunteered for
the Republican Party in the 2022
midterms he voted for you in 2020.
what's your question for the president
Wayne thank you for coming Mr President
thank you Mike my pres my question to
you is will you pardon the January 6
rioters who were convicted of federal
offenses I am inclined to Pardon many of
them I can say for every single one
because a couple of them probably they
got attic controls
this is a trap question but I think it's
a fair answer look at what they've done
Minneapolis so
many other places they want to use the
Sound Club and commercials
but I do think a lot of people always
want to know trying to certify anything
but you have two standards of Justice in
this country and what they've done and I
love that question because what they've
done to so many people is nothing
nothing and then what they've done to
these people they've persecuted these
people and yeah my my answer is I am
most likely if I get in I will most
likely I would say it will be a large
portion of them you know
they did a very
and it'll be very early on and they're
living in hell right now so when it
comes to living in hell and they're
policemen and their firemen and their
soldiers and their carpenters and
electricians and they're great people
many of them were just great people Mr
President one of the people who was
convicted was a former policeman but he
was convicted of attacking a police
officer I should note but when you said
you are considering pardoning a large
portion of those charged with crimes on
January 6. does that include the four
proud boys members who are charged and
convicted
conspiracy I don't know I'd have to look
at their case but I will say in
Washington DC you cannot get a fair
trial you cannot just like in New York
City you can't get a fair trailer
he is correct
speaking of New York I want to ask you
about a significant verdict that was
reached yesterday I know this is
something you want to weigh in on as
well a Manhattan jury found that you
sexually abused the writer E Gene
Carroll and defamed her you've denied
this the audience is laughing yeah it
disqualifies you from being president
there aren't too many of them because my
poll numbers just came out they went up
and the only person in history who had a
charge like that and the usually office
you say I'm sorry but I'm going to back
home I'm back home to my family and
everything I'm going to be my poll
numbers went up and they went up with
the other fake charge too because what's
happening is they're doing this for
election interference this woman I don't
know her I never met her I have no idea
who she is I had a picture taken years
ago with her and her husband nice guy
John Johnson he was a newscaster a very
nice man she called him an ape happens
to be African African-American called
him a name the judge wouldn't allow us
to put that in
her dog or her cat was named vagina the
judge wouldn't allowed to put that in
all of these things he but with her they
can put in anything Access Hollywood
jury of nine people who found you liable
of sexual abuse do you think that that
will deter women from voting for you no
I don't think so because I think the
whole thing is listening tonight just so
you understand ready
I never met this woman I never saw this
little Bill Clinton you did just say you
took a picture with her though
which I rarely go into other than for a
couple of Charities yeah he should
clarify I met her in the front door
she was about 60 years old and this is
like 22 23 years ago I met her in the
front door of paragraph Goodman I was
immediately attracted to her she was
immediately attracted to me and we had
this great chemistry we're walking into
a crowded department so we had this
great chemistry and a few minutes later
we end up in a a room a dressing room a
book of Goodman a cash register
and then she found out there were locks
in the door so she said I found one that
was open she found one she learned this
at trial she found one that was open
what kind of a woman meets somebody and
brings them up and within minutes you're
playing hanky-panky in a dressing room
okay I don't know if she was married
then or not John Johnson I feel sorry
for you John Mr President can I
because I was very famous then and I
owned the Plaza Hotel right next door
and I own buildings around it I'm not
going into he's right dressing room of a
crowded department store then I say if
she was being raped and by the way they
said she wasn't raped okay that was her
judge who I said they found they did
they found her what say what they did
they said he didn't rape her and they
didn't I didn't do anything else
actually they did they ruled that wasn't
true
which is
insane I tell you this but Mr President
are you ready
my children which I never do I have no
idea who this one this is a fake Story
made up story we had a horrible Clinton
appointed judge he was horrible he
allowed her to put everything in he
allowed us to put nothing in Mr Price
there's no way
walked around New York by himself
without people screaming
wouldn't have made a difference by
himself walking in nobody noticed my
lawyer said sir you don't have to do it
I actually said I think I should it
would be respectful they said sir don't
do it this is a fake story and you don't
want to give it credibility one thing
you did do in this
and I swear and I've never done that and
I swear to I have no idea who the hell
she's a black job
and Donald Trump do this without her
position of you from October in it you
defended the comments that you made on
that excess Hollywood tape about being
able to grab women going back to that
you want do you stand by those I'm not
that surprised I said if you're a little
Miss and rich or whatever I said but I
said of your star uh
you are and I said women let you I
didn't say you grandpa I said women let
you know you didn't use that word but if
you look women let you now they said
will you take that back I said look
for a million years this is the way it's
been I want to be honest that's the way
it's been I can take it back if you'd
like to but if you're a famous person if
you're a star and I'm not referring to
myself I'm saying people that are famous
people that are in the deposition people
that are rich people that are powerful
so uh they tend to do pretty well in a
lot of different ways okay
and yeah
it's been true for one million years
approximately a million years perhaps a
little bit longer than that so you stand
by those columns I don't want to lie Mr
President here's what you want
the unfamous person tonight has no
Advantage
but that's the way it is
questions to get to tonight I want to go
back to the audience we've got Danielle
Rieger she works as an oral surgery
assistant she's a republican activist
from dairy she's a New Hampshire
Delegate for you in 2020. what's your
question hi thank you so much for coming
to New Hampshire to answer our questions
my question is regarding the economy
over the past two years we have seen the
prices for everything
from food to gas to utilities and
insurance costs many people's bills are
up several hundred dollars a month
including mine if elected president
again what is is the first thing you
would do to help bring down the cost to
make things more affordable something
voters actually care about baby drill
[Applause]
good answer we were energy independent
we were soon going to be energy dominant
and nobody had ever done what I did we
got oiled down to a dollar eighty seven
actually it fell lower than that in some
cases we had to save the oil companies
when negative price was getting so we
were doing incredibly we had the
greatest economy in the history of our
country probably the greatest economy in
the history of the world we're energy
independent soon to be energy dominant
we were going to be bigger than Russia
and Saudi Arabia put together times two
we have more Liquid Gold under our feet
than any other Nation any other nation
and these stupid fools ended it and
energy went from 1.87 and even lower for
gasoline for a car they went from a
dollar 87 to 5678 and even nine dollars
and your electricity bills went through
the roof your heating bills went through
the roof and that's what started
inflation and it hasn't stopped because
people are paying now for bacon and for
eggs and for the two and three times
what it was just a little while ago we
created the greatest economy in history
a big part of that economy was I get got
you the biggest tax cuts in the history
of our country bigger than the Reagan
Cuts bigger than anything and
and also Caitlyn also as you know we got
the biggest regulation and Regulatory
Cuts we this place was rocking and then
we were given a gift from China and
China paid a big price and let me tell
you something I took in hundreds of
billions of dollars in taxes from China
but prior to covet coming in and then I
rebuilt the economy again a second time
but we had prior to covet coming in as
as from China from Wuhan which I said it
came from Wuhan everybody said oh you're
wrong about that you're wrong it came
from Wuhan I said it right from day one
so we had the greatest economy in the
world here's the story they made energy
so high and energy is all invasive it is
massive as an industry and as of course
it lifted everything if you made donuts
if you made no matter what you did she
just sounds like she's wanted inflation
the likes of which I guess we haven't
had why she debate 52 years but I think
more than that because she doesn't know
how to do anything
this country was rocking and rolling and
by the way we had the most significance
millions of jobs lost people not getting
their Social Security payments people
believe it would put the US economy into
a recession
um on that topic I want to bring in
Marta surveya a student here at St
Anselm she is an Undeclared voter who
did not vote in 2020 Marta what's your
question hi Mr President uh so my
question is what do you think about the
United States current debt situation and
how can we move forward
such an important question so we're at
33 trillion dollars a number that nobody
ever thought possible
when we had our economy rocking and
rolling just prior to covet coming in
like literally we were making a fortune
and Oil we're going to make so much
money from Oil we're going to start
paying off debt but then with covet
coming in we had to do other things we
had to keep this country alive because
it was so serious but we have to get the
country back we have to lower energy
prices we have to lower interest rates
interest rates are through the roof
energy has to come down it all has to
come down and we have to start paying
off that but when we have a debt limit
and they use that very seriously I mean
they came in Schumer came in with Nancy
Pelosi and they were using a wheel
violate it we'll do whatever they talked
a whole lot different than they do right
now I say to the Republicans out there
Congressman Senators if they don't give
you massive cuts
you're going to have to do a default do
it and I don't believe they're going to
do it before because I think the
Democrats will absolutely cave because
you don't want to have that happen but
it's better than what we're doing right
now because we're spending money like
drunken Sailors so just to be clear
you should default if the white house
does not agree
because we have to save this country our
country is dying our country is being
destroyed by stupid people by very
stupid people
using the debt ceiling as a negotiating
wedge just could not happen you you said
that when you were on the philosophy so
why is it different now that you're out
of office because now I'm not president
[Applause]
and it could be very bad it could be
maybe nothing maybe it's a you have a
bad week or a bad day
but look you have to cut your costs
we're spending seven trillion dollars on
much of it on nonsense seven trillion
dollars on nonsense
and frankly the Senate should have never
approved it get all that money that was
wasted and if they don't get rid of that
you'll have to default okay Mr President
we've got another voter here by the way
you're going to default eventually
anyway but it's going to be much Messier
I don't think you'll have to default I
think if the Republicans hold strong and
they say we want five
let's say we won five trillion dollars
off I really think the Democrats no
choice
they're going to be doing the same thing
to me in two years I guarantee you that
and they did that before
he's a member of college Republicans
he's an Undeclared voter right now he
supported you in 2020. Bobby what's your
question for president Trump hi thank
you for coming uh this is a bit of a
pivot but uh with gun violence and mass
shootings in the news cycle recently I'm
worried that state governments and the
federal government are going to ask to
repress gun rights under your
Administration you uh instructed the
Department of Justice and the ATF to ban
bump stocks if elected president again
how would you ask not only to defend our
Second Amendment rights but to restore
rights that have been taken from us by
you such as by example recently the
atf's ruling on the pistol stabilizing
braces yeah as you know the bump stocks
are actually a very unimportant thing
and NRA I went with them and they said
it doesn't mean anything or actually all
they do is teach you how to shoot very
inaccurately so we did that there's been
nobody that's protected the Second
Amendment as you know like I have I
protected it through thick and thin not
easy to do but we have a very big mental
health problem in this country and again
it's not the gun that pulls the trigger
it's the person that pulls the trigger
and we have to protect
[Applause]
us so when you were in office this year
there have already been more than 200
mass shootings in 2023 if you are real
are there any new gun restrictions that
you would sign into law I would do uh
numerous things for instance schools we
would Harden very very much hardened and
I also am a very believer I believe in
teachers I love teachers I think they're
incredible and they love the children
not quite like the parents but they love
the children in many cases almost as
much many of these teachers are soldiers
ex-soldiers ex-policemen they're people
that really understand weapons and you
don't need five percent of the teachers
would be more than you could ever have
if you're going to hire security guards
but in addition to that have security
guards you have to harden your entrances
you have to make schools safe and you
can make other places safe but it is a
big mental health problem in this
country more than anything else and
remember we have 700 million guns 700
million many people if they don't have a
gun they're not going to be very safe I
mean if they don't have a gut it gives
them security now you need them for
entertainment you need them for hunting
you need them for a lot of different
things but there are people that if they
didn't have the privilege of having a
gun in some form
they many of them would not be alive
today you know there's a certain country
that had a very strict policy on guns
very very strict
Brazil okay Brazil a very strict and the
former president of Brazil sales and the
The Killing was incredible they were
walking into people's homes and killing
people they had no protection said go
out and buy guns people went out and
bought guns and it went way down the
numbers went way down because they had
security if you look at Chicago Chicago
is the single toughest gun policies in
the nation they are so tough you can't
breathe New York too and other places
also all of those places are the worst
and most dangerous places so that's not
the answer no new restrictions that you
would sign if re-elected Mr President I
want you to meet Julie miles a
registered nurse from Mary Mack she's a
republican who voted for you in 2020.
Julie what's your question for the
president thank you Mr President thank
you I appreciate answering this question
this evening how do you plan to appeal
to Women Voters in New Hampshire who are
concerned about the Dobb's decision and
how States may change their laws it's
such a great question and it was such a
great Victory and people are starting to
understand and now you know that they
wanted to bring it back to the States
but that was probably the least
important part of that Victory getting
rid of Roe v Wade was an incredible
thing for pro-life because it gave
pro-life something to negotiate with
pro-life had absolutely nothing being
stuck in Roe v way to negotiate with and
now what's happening and I see it all
over deals are being made deals are
going to be made and it look everybody
that was President wanted to get rid and
tried to get rid of Roe v Wade for 50
years Republicans for 50 years this has
been going on actually a couple of
Democrats too but for 50 years this has
been going on I was able to do it and I
was very honored to do it but by doing
it things are happening that are very
very positive and you have to I happen
to believe in the exceptions the life of
the mother rape incest like Ronald
Reagan believed in the exceptions but I
happen to believe that I think it I
think it's frankly important to do that
but a lot of people are you know against
that a relatively small relatively small
number but the way I the way I look I
think it's very important to say this I
consider the other side to be radical
because the other side under Roe v Wade
and other things the other side they're
radical because they will remember the
development and they said rip the baby
out of the womb at the end of the ninth
month they will kill the baby
in the ninth month if you look at that
crazy governor of Virginia from the
former Governor yes well he said no the
baby will be born and then we'll decide
essentially whether or not to execute Mr
President can we talk about what you
would do it because
if you are re-elected I was gonna say he
needs to bring that up let me blush into
your desk would you sign a federal
abortion ban into law what I'll do is
negotiate so Tim's texting Trump but the
fact good job I was able I'm so proud of
it we put three great justices on the
Supreme Court we have almost 300 federal
judges
questions from Caitlyn not from the
audience I said this I said this I want
to do what's right and we're looking and
we want to do what's right for everybody
but what's right but now for the first
time the people that are pro-life have
negotiating
capability because you didn't have it
before they could kill the baby in the
ninth month or after the baby was born
now they won't be able but I think this
is a really important question for you
to answer because this is something all
every Republican including those who are
running against you for the nomination
are being asked about is would you sign
a federal abortion ban into law and many
of them are going to give you the same
answers I I am first of all I am honored
to have done what I did and a lot of
people said they said in 150 years he's
now the most consequential president
because he saved so many lives and I'm
honored to have got it
and
and because of what I've done we now
have a great negotiating ability that's
what I do in life I negotiate we have a
great negotiating ability and I think
we're going to be able to get
negotiating finally because the question
that Republicans have and some of you
know
they're saying that when it comes to
Banning abortion if they send it to your
desk would you sign it some people are
at six weeks some people are at three
weeks here we go good answer president
Trump is going to make a determination
what he thinks is great for the country
and what's fair for the country but the
fact that I was able to terminate Roe v
Wade after 50 years of trying they work
for 50 years I've never seen anything
like it they worked and I was even I was
so honored to have done it we are in a
very good negotiating position right now
only because of what I was able to do
and remember this oh he's not going to
again you talk about radicalism people
that will kill a baby in the ninth month
or the eighth month or the seventh month
or after the baby is born they're the
radicals not the programs
[Applause]
how many weeks into pregnancy you
believe abortion should be banned yeah
but can you answer I'm giving you the
answer probably four times already which
one I'm looking I'm looking at a
solution that's going to work very
complex issue for the country you have
people on both sides of an issue but we
are now in a very strong position
pro-life people are in a strong position
to make a deal that's going to be good
and going to be satisfactory for them if
you weren't able to get rid of you
wouldn't be having a discussion if you
weren't able to get rid of Roe v Wade
which put pro-life in a dead position a
horrible position they could kill the
baby at any time they wanted to but we
did something that nobody thought was
doable and other Republican presidents
and others by the way they wanted to get
it out they also wanted to bring it back
to the States but bringing it back to
the states is a less important issue
abortion band you did not say yes or no
to that it depends what the deal is
Lindsey Graham
that uh I'm impressed so far the
beginning was a little slow but I'm I'm
impressed with uh where we got so far
that was that was 40 minutes with no
commercials another new commercial I
guess they only got one one commercial
break or something and he must know how
long this I mean that's one of the
reasons he probably kept the
filibustering yeah with the abortion
thing I was like he's got to hit at how
these states are enacting
restrictionless outright abortion at
nine months viability all of that stuff
because most Americans find that
completely unreasonable right and then I
I think Trump's got some really great
stuff going on where he's like well I'm
not president you know like that's that
was really good I was President
yes it was really good it was good that
he had the time stamps and she she would
not accept that she was wrong I gotta
say what is she doing this is it's crazy
to me when we had lands from the surf's
on last week and we did this a lot a lot
of people get mad they're like why
wasn't you know we had Destiny on why
wasn't Tim drilling Destiny and going
crazy because we're not debating it's a
debate show half half of the time like
sometimes they'll say something that is
wrong and I'll be like no no that's
incorrect you can't say that sometimes
they'll be like I believe X because of
this reason and I'll go okay like you're
allowed to have a moral position and an
opinion I I can't be like your opinion
is wrong I'm just like oh I died okay
and then what they try to do is they say
like oh Tim got owned or whatever no
this is the problem with the modern left
default liberals or leftists Caitlyn
Collins thinks no matter what Trump says
she has to try and get him instead of
saying Trump what's your thoughts on
this
thank you for telling us that next
question what are your thoughts on this
instead you're like nope you're wrong
nope you're wrong wrong that's where
she's coming from she wants to get him
and like it's she's made it her personal
mission yeah to get him on every answer
and also to get that sound bite that
they can put into every commercial for
the next two weeks and for her own uh
prowess right like she is looking I'm
looking at this examiner article uh
there's speculation that they'll offer
Chris Cuomo spot right so she is trying
to launch her career off of getting
Trump to say the infamous sound bite she
wants that to be her Moment Like This is
right she is she's in broadcast yeah she
wants her Megan Kelly moment she does
that Megan kelly didn't even get yeah
right so I just I I don't know what they
with the with with this guy licked guy
sees and Kalyn Collins I'm like I can
understand having her be a reporter but
giving her a show then having her host a
presidential Town Hall it's just not
there like Anderson Cooper I get Kalyn
Collins I don't get
I you know well Megan Kelly is good she
she did a great job with Trump
there there are a lot of people I think
could do way better than her I think
there are
um I think CNN thinks about the way its
voters want to see Trump portrayed right
and that makes sense it's their Channel
but I think conservative viewers tend to
want a moderator who's going to keep the
conversation going and who isn't there
to just fact check whereas MSNBC CNN
tends to staff people who are there to
fact check everyone involved in debates
and it becomes really I had a professor
when I was at SMU who did a study on
this who said uh you know you find that
left-leaning mainstream media
they spend a lot of time saying well
well actually that's not correct whereas
when you're on Fox or a different
different network it tends to be more
just about making sure that you're
hearing from enough people they're
actually sort of holding the true
position of a moderator well I think
they also want to have a woman on there
so that it can be this combative thing
that they can say oh you know look at
how dismissive he is of the moderator
you know she's asking all these really
good questions and he won't answer them
and then he he says mean things to her
and it pulls up his finger yeah and
holds up his finger like how would how
dare you do that to a woman you don't
hold up your finger you know I just got
I just got ideas I'm watching these
scene on commercials
we should run commercials on CNN sure
that'd be really funny Tim cast IRL
commercial they'd be pretty cheap right
now I think yeah I think I think they're
like eight grand for 30 seconds you know
how with like NPR if they're doing a
story on something they have to
occasionally say like just in full
transparency you know apple is a sponsor
of NPR or whatever and CNN would have to
be like when they report on you just to
be clear is a sponsor we're back welcome
back to Republican Presidential town
hall with former president Donald Trump
uh president Trump I'd like to meet
Jennifer she is a stay-at-home mom and
former town selectman from Wyndham she's
a Republican and she voted for you in
2020. Jennifer what's your question good
evening Mr President title 42 is
expected to expire tomorrow our Southern
border and now our northern border are
experiencing record migration we learned
on May 2nd that the Biden Administration
plans on deploying 1500 troops to the
southern border do you agree with
deploying troops to the border and how
will a trump Administration slow down
the rate of migrants coming across all
our borders sure
a very fair question especially since
tomorrow is going to be a day of infamy
oh yeah you're going to have tens of
thousands of people pouring into our
country even the judge you know the
judge overruled them when they wanted to
terminate it early and he said you know
that you better extend this thing the
judge in Texas said I hope you're going
to extend this but this is my policy
that they're letting terminate because
they lost some good they wanted to go
earlier you're going to have millions of
people pouring into our country right
now at a level that nobody's ever seen
before these people are sick anybody
that wants this to happen to our country
they're destroying our country and this
should not be allowed to happen how
they're not going to do a version of
title 42 or my title 42 which was tough
if people are sick and have infectious
diseases and lots of other problems we
don't want them being into our country
we have enough problems right now we
have problems like we've never had in
the history of our country our country
is
ending is because the health policy the
covet era pandemic emergency is coming
to an end that's what title 42 was you
put it in place
when it comes to Big questions about
what your immigration policy would look
like if you are re-elected some of your
Republican Rivals have criticized you
for not fulfilling the promises that you
made on the campaign Trail like
finishing the border wall so how do
voters know that you would get those
done if you're re-elected I did finish
the wall I built a wall I built hundreds
of miles of wall and I finished it and
then I said we have to build some more
because there are areas like water going
through a dam there are some areas where
a lot of people are coming you close up
one and they come into another and we
started another 100 miles of wall in
fact I said to my people if we start
this and don't finish it and then we had
a rigged election I'm sorry to say it
the election
in three weeks he shouldn't bring in
miles of wall if we didn't have look
a country has said I think it is funny
though that she has never been anything
like that is happening to our country
two miles of new wall when you were in
office Mr President it wasn't the
complete wall one other thing that with
nobody likes to respond to that with
your immigration it was only about 15.
this is what she does
I built hundreds of miles some of the
wall was up there and it would be laying
on the ground arrested rotten to Steel
rusted rotten wood a little and what the
radical left crazy Democrats did if
there's a piece of wood laying down they
consider that a wall I built 30-foot
walls that go down seven feet into the
ground if there was a little piece of
wood sitting in the ground they said oh
he's not building a wall we already had
a wall because this is the game they're
a party of disinformation it's not a
game Mr President it's about 52 miles
that was up and rotting in the ground
for 30 years some of it was steel that
you couldn't see because it was only
about 52 miles of new wall but moving on
another immigration policy you had was
the zero tolerance immigration policy
that separated families at the border if
you are realized
you're not going to talk about the truth
people don't come if the family hears
that they're going to be separated they
love their family they don't come so I
know it sounds harsh but if you remember
remember this that I was building
prisons for children it turned out that
it was Obama that was built kids and
cases
we have to save our country all right
that's a yes
when you say to a family that if you
come we're going to break you up they
don't come and we can't afford to have
any more look at New York City look
what's happening they're living in
Central Park in New York City the city
is being swamped Los Angeles is being
swamped Iowa is being swamped our whole
country is being destroyed millions of
people are coming into our country and
you know what the number is going to be
in my opinion by the end of the year not
the 4 million that you hear in the 3
million until I think it's going to be
15 million people and in these people
they have no idea where they come from
they come from 129 different countries
so far 120 not just the four that we
talked to put a button on that it sounds
like what you're saying is that you're
not ruling out re-implementing that
immigration policy I want to get to
another voter Caitlin plazo is a student
here at St Anselm College she's a
republican this will be the first
election that she has voted in what's
her question for the president Caitlin
hello president Chum thank you so much
the current Administration has made it
clear that we should continue to provide
military equipment to Ukraine so that
they can defend themselves do you
support this decision and how would you
deal with the increasing threat posed by
Vladimir Putin first of all thank you
very much it's really nice and it's an
important question so important because
we're giving away so much equipment we
don't have ammunition for ourselves
right now we don't have ammunition for
ourselves we're giving away so much but
here's the thing I have to say it to
start off no longer matters if I were
president this would have never happened
and even the Democrats admit that Putin
knew it would have never happened and
his pipeline would have never happened a
lot of things would have never happened
but this would never have happened and
all those dead people both Russian and
Ukrainian it would they wouldn't be dead
today and all those cities that are
blown up and disintegrated right to the
ground that wouldn't have happened okay
now here's the problem we've given so
far 171 billion dollars
they've given meaning they meaning
European Union which is approximately
the same size altogether as our economy
they've given about 20. so we're at 170
let's say and there are 20. uh you don't
have to know too much about history to
realize your geography to realize that
they're a little bit more effective than
we are okay so they've got to put up a
lot more money because they're taking
advantage of us like every other country
did that's why I ended NAFTA and replace
it with the usmca of Mexico issue Mr
President I I should know I don't know
any Democrats who have said they don't
believe Putin would have been invaded if
you were president but her question is
would you continue to give Ukraine money
and weapons if you're elected so she
remembers this girl's questions with uh
president zielinski because as you know
he backed me up with the with the phony
uh impeachment impeachment hoax number
one when he said
the president didn't do anything wrong
so I happen to like yeah that's right
and it was I was totally exonerated by
the way just a waste of time and money
you were impeached
impeached does not mean convicted
Caitlyn Collins
doesn't need to know the details
impeached by a crazy woman named Nancy
weapons and funding if you were I would
sit down let me just put it a nice way
uh if I'm president I will have that War
settled in one day 24 hours I agree
[Applause]
they both have weaknesses and they both
have strengths and within 24 hours that
war will be settled it'll be over it'll
be absolutely do you know what Ukraine I
win this war uh I don't think in terms
of winning and losing I think in terms
of getting it settled so we stopped
killing all these people
shot fast
what can I just follow up on that you
said you don't think you have to do is
follow up on that because that's a
really important excuse me
can you say if you want Ukraine or
Russia to win this war
I want everybody to stop dying yes
Russians look good here
and I'll have that done
you need the power of the presidency to
do it but you won't say that you want
Ukraine to win oh God
I want Europe to put up more money
because they're in for 20 billion we're
in for 170 and they should answer and
they should equalize they have plenty of
money they should equalize I got with
NATO that's when I sat down I got them
to put up hundreds and billions of
dollars under Obama and Bush and all of
these other presidents that's why
they're able to help them fight the war
because of the money I got but I want
Europeans I want Europe to put up more
money because they're laughing at us
they think we're a bunch of jerks we're
spending 170 billion dollars for far
away land and they're right next door to
that land
and they're in for 20. I don't think so
when it comes to what's happening there
when you were in office you said that
you respected President Putin do you
still respect him today uh he made a
tremendous mistake I mean he met he's a
smart guy you know I remember I said he
was smart she was smart he said
president XI of China right is smart
Okay 1.5 billion people he's the ruler
of 1.5 billion people I said yeah he's a
smart guy how dare he say he's smart of
course he's smart they want you to say
he's a stupid person okay he's not a
stupid person he's very smart he's very
cunning and Putin made a bad mistake in
my opinion what was his name his mistake
was going in he would have never gone in
If I Was President we used to talk I
agree
do you believe that he is a war criminal
what do you believe that Putin is a war
criminal
he's responsible for the deaths of
thousands well I think this I think it's
something that should not be discussed
now it should be discussed later because
right now we have to go to war if you
say he's a war criminal it's going to be
a lot tougher to make a deal to get this
yeah because if he's going to be more
equipment where people are going to go
and grab him and execute him he's going
to fight a lot harder than he's fighting
you know under the other circumstance uh
that's something to be discussed at a
later date right now we want to get that
War settled okay and I'm not talking
about the money either I'm talking about
the lives that are being the number of
people Town Hall can we talk about
domestic issues and those buildings come
pouring down and they say two people
were injured no no hundreds and
thousands of people are being killed and
we have to get that War settled we have
more with former president Trump right
after this we're going to take a quick
break and we'll be back the questions
from voters right after that I think the
Ukraine thing is a domestic issue
because we were 170 billion in sure so I
I like the fact that they went went
there I think he handled that really
well and I agree I think she was looking
to to get him to say something stupid
and he stayed on point I think he hit it
out of the park Grand Slam bases knocked
it out when she's like do you want
Ukraine to win will you say it he's like
I want everyone to stop dying he nailed
it exactly you can't get him they can't
sound bite that because he's right and
that's she looked horrible because she
kept asking the same question after he
answered it very succinctly she only
does that when she has a soundboard that
she a sound bite that she's trying to
get do you think Putin's a war criminal
and then Trump nailed it he's like look
if we call him a war criminal how are we
going to negotiate and end of the war
he's gonna say
we're gonna wait on that in fact the
fact that she even brings it up on
national television with as many viewers
is watching is bad for trying to end the
war but you know what they don't want
the war to end no I bet a guy in her ear
said say poon's a war criminal because
we want it on TV yeah we want Putin to
think that if the war ends he dies yeah
that way he never stops yeah and and
Putin and Trump had a strong Rapport
when he was in office they want to try
and make Trump uh an impossible choice
if you want to end the war too they want
Putin to be against him let me let me uh
Mitchy cool says did you all hear
Collins call him Mr President
yeah yeah but she also wants to hurt
hurt him with conservatives because if
he's on team Ukraine that hurts him with
lots of conservatives before before it
comes back I want to just address the
the election thing when people so as
many people are pointing out everybody
wants to say that the election was
rigged if you're talking about the
Democrats changed rules so they could
get Universal mail and voting they could
go to nursing homes they could ballot
Chase bout Harvest and all of these
things that were deemed legal by the
courts I agree I think it's shady I
think we should have one day of voting
that's why we should have reforms we
should have a day of voting we should
have voter ID we should have paper
ballots I agree with all of that but
when so if you're saying that's what you
mean by rigged I get it and you had that
article in Time Magazine but what what
I'm trying to make sure we're not
talking about is the idea that like
China was sending fake ballots that the
machines were printing fake things or
anything like that
I think the Democrats outplayed the
Republicans heavily exploiting covid and
that's what got biting these votes and
I've seen people do it when Trump starts
drifting into that which people don't
understand and he's like oh it's all
right he's talking about the past he's
not talking about what you can expect
from him he's not telling the people
what he's going to give you if you vote
for him and I think that's what they
want together they want to push him in
that direction because it hurts him in
the polls yeah they spent the first 25
minutes really just talking about his
character it wasn't anything other
anything that really affects the people
other than his character and they spent
the first 25 minutes on that they just
read a commercial for the Town Hall
that's airing right now while we're
watching it while we were watching it
just ran in case you were wondering
what's going on tonight I thought it was
back I was like oh is it back no it's a
commercial for an hour ago it might be
just online only though I bet right on
TV they're not doing it no it's on TV
yeah we're yeah so uh so I just want to
say man when Donald Trump came out and
said we are going to start ballot
harvesting ballot chasing that gave me
hope because it's like ah he understands
what they did they wrote an article
explaining what they did people went to
nursing homes and this is all legal this
is legally done and they said fill out
your ballot do this give it to me sign
me off as your caretaker I'll drop it
off for you and there was this there's a
guy I can't remember what state it was
it might have been Pennsylvania where he
was like it's legal you're allowed to do
it you are allowed to go to nursing
homes Republicans just did not do it
Democrats outground game them I think
they're about to come back on here
I think that's been a true of the
democratic party for some time they are
good at working on the ground to get
what they want uh I think what bothers
me about this whole thing is that the
mainstream media opinion writers already
have submitted their pieces talking
about how great Caitlyn is doing tonight
uh they will be out by midnight here we
go we're back we're back
in presidential town hall with former
president Trump president Trump
we have a lot more
of a should note and here in New
Hampshire to get to but I also want to
talk about some of the other
investigations that you're facing we
talked about others at the top but one
of those is the special counsel's
investigation into classified documents
that were found at Mar-A-Lago why did
you take those documents with you when
you left the White House I had every
right to under the presidential records
act you have the presidential records
act I was there and I took what I took
and it gets Declassified Biden on the
other hand he has 1850 boxes he had
boxes sent to Chinatown Chinatown where
they don't speak even English in that
Chinatown we're talking about it right
there no you don't shut up uh just so
you understand I had every right to do
it I didn't make a secret of it you know
the boxes were stationed outside of the
White House people were taking pictures
of the GSA of the various people right
there then because the presidential
records act which is not well known to a
lot of people I read it it does not say
I read it documents with you it says
actually that they are the property it
says you talk you negotiate you make a
deal it's not Criminal by the way not
it's the presidential records
criminal and uh just so you know how you
can negotiate just show you the
documents with you can I tell you just
so you understand the presidential
records Act is not criminal I took the
documents I'm allowed to you know who
else took them Obama took them Nixon
took them
yes he did Obama Hillary took the
furniture yeah
even Jimmy Carter even Mike Pence had
some documents and he's a very honorable
guy you referenced but you never took
him more than anybody is Joe Biden he
has 1800 boxes
Obama did take records they were brought
somewhere and the media argued it was
totally fine it's legal the way he did
it
they're in Chicago
they took documents including president
or vice president Pence when they
realized they had documents they turned
them back over the difference is that
you waited to turn yours over and it was
a year and a half effort that included a
subpoena with those documents one
question
go to my house that's what it included
they had not been turned over yet they
didn't raid Biden's house you know what
happened they put him in the house
that's the one with the Corvette where
the documents were laying all over the
floor that was fine you can see them in
the garage
Secret Service and they're phenomenal I
have Secret Service he didn't have
Secret Service the other thing the vice
president cannot declassify he didn't
have the right to declassify he has
documents from when he was a Senator and
even Democrat Senator to say it I can't
believe it no I went by the presidential
records act and we were negotiating with
Nara that's not what it says Mr
President the Constitution of the United
States and the Bill of Rights because
they considered them that's not what it
says and I should note that there are is
a special counsel investigating your
document situation also President
Biden's document situation when it comes
to you guys did you ever show those
qualified documents to anyone not really
I would have the right to by the way
they would Declassified after not that I
can think of let me just tell you I have
the absolute right to do whatever I want
with them I have the right I was
negotiating with narid you know what
Nara is the National Archives extremely
extremely left a group of people
extremely left and I was negotiating
with them all of a sudden they raided my
house they didn't Caitlin yeah they
didn't rate Obama
subpoena to get those documents
150 bucks
questions
okay it's very simple to answer that's
why I asked it except yourself it's very
simple
when we left Washington we had the boxes
lined up on the sidewalk outside for
everybody people are taking pictures of
them everybody knew we were taking those
boxes and the GSA the government service
the GSA was the one taking them they
brought them down to mar-a-laga we were
negotiating with Nara all of a sudden
they raid our house
when Biden had his documents he won't
give back the 1850 boxes and you're
going to find some real gems in there
to hear the documents the National
Archives reached out to YouTube
why are we even talk about it
I understand why this is even a topic
associated with them
the presidential records
Richard Nixon surprisingly had problems
and he had a lot of problems dealing
with Nara and they ended a passing
legislation that's why they called the
presidential records act just for this
kind of a thing we were dealing with
them excuse me
we were talking to them we would have
done this question
why haven't why hasn't the FBI raided
Biden but I just explained to you why
it's because they alerted the government
that they had those documents and had
them come and get the dogs
in your possession
are you ready do you no no I don't have
anything I have no classified documents
and by the way they become automatically
Declassified when I took them but why do
classes let me ask you no you don't why
is it that Biden had nine boxes in China
all the time she knows what she's
talking about there's no process by
which the president doesn't want to be
classified anything she is a legal
scholar
in journalism at University of Alabama
why don't they put him in charge of that
I need to stop you right there because
there's no evidence of what you just
said there what you're interested
the vice president he had a temporary
office but I want to ask about another
investor
University of Pennsylvania but he also
had nine years that you're facing which
is the one that's happening in Georgia
where they are investigating their your
efforts to overturn the election results
in the state of Georgia perfect phone
call let me finish my question is that
call that you had with the secretary
bradfordsberger yeah sure given the fact
that there are indictments expected to
come in that case this summer is that a
call you would make again today yeah I
called questioning the election I
thought it was a rigged election I
thought I'd had a lot of problems I had
every I guess he's Secretary of State I
called listen to this there are like
seven lawyers in the call many of them
from there were having a quote we're
having a normal call nobody said oh gee
he shouldn't have said that why if this
call was bad I questioned the election
I didn't ask him to find anything let me
just heard the audience
sold me votes because the election was
rigged that election was rigged and if
this call was bad why didn't him and his
lawyers hang up how dare you say that
this was a person they were clearly
concerned enough they recorded the call
and I should note that this was a call
that was made to question the the
results of election and we have and when
we can't make a call to question
election results then this country ought
to just forget about it you weren't just
questioning yourself
I disagree with Trump there is no
evidence of fraud there is no Bridge
election you have to be able to call and
have a religious ingredients because
those are false claims you're making
about what happened in Georgia
been answering the question at all he
voted for you that's probably the best
way he could Jordan what is your
question thank you Mr Trump thank you
very much I'm 26 I'm a veteran I helped
manage a private Aviation company
um you want a job I'd love one yeah yeah
I'm looking for somebody very good I uh
I'm not from mandated government
interference in private business but
I've seen Republicans going after us
like DeSantis after Disney right what
would you do as president to protect us
from government interference well I'm
the one that really wants to protect you
all of these fake investigations of me
are about election interference they
think because I'm leading Biden by 11
points seven points nine points I'm
leading to sanctimonious by a lot by 40
points so 45 points I think he ought to
just relax and take it easy and think
about the future because right now his
future is not looking so good I will
tell you this we are really putting it
to Biden but he's putting it to himself
because the economy stinks inflation is
horrible and the border is is a disaster
and by the way the way he got out of
Afghanistan was the single most
embarrassing moment in the history of
our country
but Des sanctimonious come on not a fan
of that yeah this is a fundamental
question for you you were running in the
2024 race if you are the Republican
nominee and you were in that 2024 will
you commit tonight to accepting the
results of the 2024 election yeah if I
think it's an honest election absolutely
answer the election regardless of the
outcome you want me to answer it again
if I think it's an honest election I
would be honored to and right now we are
so far ahead of both Democrat and
Republican
and you know what if I don't win this
country is going to be in big trouble
it's so sad to see what's happening but
if it's an honest election correct okay
so not committing to accepting the 2020
horror election results
important conversation
thank you to our audience audience and
to our host Saint Anselm College
students coverage continues with
Anderson
it certainly does not continue with us I
don't want to hear what those people
have to say goodness yeah oh man that
was oh look he's a cool guy Jake
tapper's so awesome the reason why she
keeps going back to the election fraud
stuff is because it pulls very poorly
with independent voters that's where
they need to strike Donald Trump
succeeded in 2016 by switching 9 million
moderate leaning Democrats to the
Republican party every time they get
Trump to say it's rigged it's rigged
it's rigged he is losing votes and
that's why they're doing it that's why
in the beginning of the show they went
after him over and over and over again
and it is a large reason why I'm telling
people and I beg people please stop like
whatever it is you think
the Democrats had a tremendous ground
game okay they they were able to find
the votes and you've got to counter it
Scott Pressler style and you need to
back off from it if you want to win the
moderates over in this die-hard Trump
supporters uh are falling into this trap
and and CNN just showed you exactly how
they do it they know that Trump's
biggest fans and biggest supporters are
going to reject any notion that the
election was anything that they know
that if they come out and say it wasn't
it wasn't fraud Trump supporters are
going to come out and say yes it was and
they're going to get them to say it over
and over and over again to make as many
sounds sound bites as possible and I
would not be surprised if the next time
they have a show they're going to be
like how many times did Trump say rigged
and they're going to play it on repeat
and they're going to put in the face of
as many Independents as possible
instead of showing Trump saying things
like we need people to stop dying which
was a grand slam that's why I'm like
guys
talk about the future who said talk
about the future stop talking about the
past yeah right do you think that when
it comes time for the Republican primary
the other Republicans will continue to
bring this up because they know it hurts
Trump absolutely yeah I wouldn't be
surprised if Rhonda Sanders comes out
and says you know Democrats they got
Universal mail-in voting they were they
were changing voting laws in their
states in some instances like
Pennsylvania the Republicans were
involved that things like voter in the
park and their videos where uh State
reps and judges are like you are allowed
to ballot harvest in the state I think
there's only there's only a handful of
six that actually explicitly ban it it's
illegal in many forms in many states
usually with some restrictions where
like you can only Carry Three at a time
and then you'll see videos like James
O'Keefe had Bill Barr said there was
some fraud she said there was none she's
wrong Bill bar said there was some but
not nearly enough there's always a
little bit there were a bunch of federal
prosecutions over voter fraud sure but I
don't think it was in the tens of
millions or significant enough to have
as big of an impact as people want I
think what people are thinking of when
they say rigged is that Democrats change
the rules anyway I don't even want to
get get wrapped up in this they change
the rules but sometimes they didn't
abide by the rules at all like in in
Pennsylvania they did things that were
actually illegal for them to do and they
didn't have like authority to do it
um changing the changing the laws on uh
another Universal like well so a judge
so here's the issue the lower court said
you can't change this law without going
to a newspaper and getting a
constitutional amendment right and then
everyone was like wow the lower courts
are agreeing with the Republicans the
problem is the Republicans actually
worked with the Democrats to pass that
law so when it went to the Supreme Court
they were like no this was done by both
parties and now one party's coming out
after the fact so I don't I think it's
all partisan I think when you look at
what's going on in New York you can see
it's pure tribalism but I think you can
just see very obviously why CNN kept
asking that question oh they want the
sound bite because it hurts Republicans
and when I hear him say that over and
over again and he won't let it go and
they know they can get him on it I'm
like I see DeSantis going up and I and I
like Trump's answer on the War I think
it's important but let's let's do this
we're going to jump to this story maybe
uh uh maybe the last story before we go
to super chats
ladies and gentlemen we made the news in
Trump's trial a secret fight over a
juror's right-wing news source I love
this because this proves to all of you
it's a cult check it out
they say
e Gene Carroll's lawyers tried to
exclude the man who listened to podcasts
by the provocateur Tim Poole he remained
on the jury that found the ex-president
libel provocateur is a great word
provocateur I like that what what do I
do they call Milo yiannopoulos a
provocateur well he goes out he gives
speeches do I do do I ever leave this
building do I make phone calls to
anybody do I contact members of Congress
or do I just sit here and have
conversations with people the beauty is
very provocative it is I have to say and
evocative
take a look at this the juror was a 31
year old man who said he lived in the
Bronx for all his life during jury
selection he he said that he tended to
avoid news but listen to Independent
podcasts every now and then and listen
listed one example
the original transcript inaccurately
captured the podcast title as Temple but
lawyers from his Carroll the writer who
filed the lawsuit according to uh
accusing Mr Trump of rape later learned
through news reports that the anonymous
juror identified only as 077 had
actually said he listens to Tim Poole
here's the best part you guys ready for
this Mr pool's YouTube channel includes
dozens of recordings that push
hard-right views his podcast which has
been criticized as a vector for
conspiracy theories is called the
culture War well hold on there a minute
the culture war is a new show that has
been hasn't been accused of anything
it's never been in the news it's only
been around for about two months 11
episodes that's fake news and I I wonder
if that's actually defamatory in that
you could argue things about timcast IRL
the show y'all are watching now because
it's been around for years and has been
in the news several times but the
culture War hasn't been no the culture
War podcast hasn't been covered by
anyone and I'm surprised they even found
it you know what they did they searched
for Tim pool podcast and found the
culture War podcast with Tim Poole which
is a new show which has very little
viewership relative to this show or even
Tim cast news it's a vector a vector
that's why they said dozens of
recordings
a bit more than dozens yeah I think IRL
has like 2 000 or something like that
and then the culture War has like 25.
and the morning videos that you do I
mean you put out a dozen morning videos
five videos a day right on timcast news
and there's like 3 000 videos also they
don't even mention like you like worked
for vice like you're such a lefty and so
many other issues they're like this far
right guy yeah you you would imagine New
York Times would do a little bit more
research and have figured that out I
know you wouldn't
during the confidential questioning jira
77 said that Mr pool quote is like
middle adding that the podcaster gets
different political figures or just
celebrities like that on the left on the
right Duro 79 and also describe the
podcast as balanced do you know why yeah
he watched this show probably because we
had like a run-of-the-mill celebrity on
the show one time right this is a guy
who apparently said that he only He's
only seen a few episodes and it may be
because we've had musicians we've had
people like Ethan simply on the show an
actor and we just we just talked about
you know moderate political issues we
have had people who are totally
apolitical who struggle to even talk
with it's scientists doctors
but they don't know anything about it
this is the first show that I've ever
watched of yours yeah so the one you're
on yeah the one I'm on here you go
welcome he said that he'd been doing
doubles at work and listen listen to Mr
pool's show three or four times in the
past six months said he never had heard
of Miss Carol and was confident he could
be fair to both sides here's a guy who
actually said Trump is liable for sexual
abuse not rape after almost 30 years
that's amazing and they're like that's a
fan of Tim pool who should be removed
from the jury here's what they said look
at this a lawyer from his Carol said
that the juror appeared to get his news
from a single really virulently
extremist podcast it's amazing but I can
sit here being like Trump is wrong about
the fraud narrative and I'm pro-choice
and they're a lot he's an extremist but
you see what they're trying to do
two things they they want to create a a
bifurcation between me and regular
people because they don't want regular
people to hear honest commentary from
honest people
and well I mean I I'll I'll leave it at
that that's that's basically it to
defame and to push people away so those
are the two things I guess so he wasn't
dismissed no and then he actually sided
with them
right and what's what's the story here
then I don't know why is it why isn't
curious why this is actually a story why
is it that they they ran that story
about the Allen Texas shooter yeah who
posted four clips of me and then in the
same week they're like a right-wing
extremist news source there's no news
here the guy said he listened to the
show three or four times and that was
the end of it they didn't dismiss him
and then he sided with them why is the
New York Times Politico The Daily Beast
whoever else they're all writing this up
because they're afraid of you I mean I
think it's because you take their
audience and also you actually do have a
lot of moderate views unlike both
mainstream Fox News and all the
mainstream leveling Publications like
that's just how it is that's got to see
it because there's no other reason to
say oh did you know there was a juror
that wasn't dismissed but he admitted
that he watched this show four times and
people are like three times who weren't
aware of you or IRL already have heard
your name probably because of the Allen
Texas stuff so New York Times jumping on
this bandwagon that I think they often
look I mean because it's not the first
time you've trended I think people want
this show to be something uh more
extreme so they can shun it they want
you to have every time they Google your
name they want far right extremist
terrible person to come up but it
doesn't work it doesn't work because you
do this show every night and prove them
wrong they definitely turned band camp
off to you well band camp spreading
defamation or something like that but
there there there's a cult they're
extremists and the people who watch this
show probably already agree with me when
we say these people are in a cult
because you can have a leftist like
Lance from the surfs on the show overtly
say he's pro-abortion at any time for
any period for any reason Matt Bender
are left to say the exact same thing
sitting next to Sheamus Coughlin a
Catholic conservative pro-lifer who
wants abortion banned outright and me
saying well I think there should be some
restrictions but maybe only after
viability which is the middle
and the person on the left says you're
all far right
like right if my opinion and and you
know is the average opinion based on
polling then what are they talking about
they're just lying that's what they do
they lie and I'm I'm part of partly
grateful because this makes it easy to
prove they're lying
that's it is there is there anybody else
that has as many
diverse people on their podcast as you
do I mean I mean there's certainly you
right well I like I think Patrick Bet
David uh has way more uh people across
because what they really want to do is
silence everybody not just you but
silence everybody that you would ever
have on and make sure they can put those
people into a box right and because you
know CNN's never going to have those
people on Fox News won't have them on
either Fox News won't have people on who
they're afraid of are associated with
people even if that person has never
done it two layers deep yeah you'll be
like yeah you will you you went to this
one party with this guy you know like
whatever
I think this is actually political wrote
up an even bigger story saying there was
inferred bias or whatever Tim Poole a
far-right pro-trump commentator who has
aligned himself with figures like Steve
Bannon what does that even aligned
himself with people like Steve Bannon it
means you talked to him one time and you
didn't scream in his face but I we we on
the the show the members only show I we
argued about the fraud narrative and I
told him to his face he was wrong and I
said Trump was unelected he was
anti-elected people voted against him
and we went in this long thing and he
was like well that's an interesting
point and I think he's been in the show
twice yeah what what is this you're not
allowed to platform it at all you're not
allowed to talk to people no no talking
to other people when I when I say the
association game associate him with some
someone that right most people dislike
so make make those associations and like
we can then create a box around these
people who make commentary with some
sense exactly when I think of you the
first thing I think of is not he's
pro-trump
no most people don't yeah like now me
most I think it's fair if somebody says
that they think of me as pro-trump
because like all I did was make memes
about Trump
but but for them to call you the
pro-trump extremist is just hilarious it
it doesn't it doesn't fit at all they
debunking themselves especially when we
have like Lou gradkowski on this show
for like seven months at a time and
people say he has Trump derangement
syndrome or Ian Crossland who says some
of like the craziest leftist stuff half
the time and then rolls twenties the
other half like the the it's it's
you know look
for legal reasons I'll say this is
besmirching my good name and I am
concerned about reputational damage
which we'll be pursuing but part of me
is like okay dude make me more famous my
name's all over the Press now and people
are wondering what this is all about
yeah I love I love their New York Times
writing about the culture War great we
need to press because that you weren't
going to get in there if it wasn't bad
press which all press is good for us and
you know what man I mean I don't even
know if it's even bad press we'll see
we'll see I don't know and they always
tell you like you get into a car
accident don't say you're fine because
you don't actually know what injuries
you might have and there's so many
stories where someone gets like T-boned
and then like well I feel okay I think
we're good and then a year later like
actually in that accident you chip the
bone and now you need like a ten
thousand dollar surgery or 100 000
surgery so it's like you know we'll see
we'll see maybe you know but uh we
sponsor ourselves we're building our own
companies we we are member supported I'm
not worried about companies dropping us
in terms of sponsorships
I'm not worried about it at all and now
with Twitter Rumble competing with
YouTube I'm not worried about YouTube
either there's nothing they can do
they've lost the the the the things
they've said like when Keith olberman's
tweeting at me and like this this Allen
Texas thing comes up I'm like literally
I don't care what these people think at
all there is no concern I have none we
have built infrastructure we are
building infrastructure Rumble is
building infrastructure Elon Musk is
building infrastructure what do we have
to be worried about at this point say
whatever stupid garbage fine we'll sue
you if it's defamatory and you'll lose
true and it has no impact did Keith come
out of retirement to attack you he
retired he's retiring for he's retired
like four times from Twitter uh wow he
retires a lot I guess
Let's uh let's do one more uh One More
Story
Let's uh where are we at here we go this
one's big ladies and gentlemen Bud
Lights hangover from Hell sales figures
for America's once favorite beer reveal
how every region in the US has turned
its back since the Dylan Mulvaney tie up
check this out in every region Bud Light
sales are plunging so in in the east
north central is that what they call
that East North Central which is like
Illinois Indiana Ohio and Wisconsin
Michigan 23.5 percent
in the east south central it's 25 in
West North Central 25 in Mount in the
mountain region it's negative 29 percent
everywhere nice wow I saw the story
earlier today that uh gay bars in
Chicago aren't buying Bud Light because
they're boycotting it because they're
also boycotting because the brand didn't
stand behind Dylan Mulvaney enough like
they can't win they have really shot
themselves on both sides on that exactly
oh my gosh this is great uh we're
winning so you know for those that uh
didn't hear we were talking about the
last in the previous segment just about
how the New York Times and Politico are
smearing my good name and lying about
this show
I don't know how much it matters they
have no influence anymore
I I go out and people smile and wave
shake my hand I can take pictures with
me people who watch the show these are
Urban centers this is what I think
they're really afraid of they were in
New York City and a an urban liberal New
York City guy says oh yeah Listen to Tim
pool's podcast and they're like oh crap
yeah we're losing Urban liberals that's
a problem
well and they'll be losing liberals in
New York City
way faster if they don't get it turned
around soon because New York City is
just absolute garbage
yeah well this is what I'm saying
everybody with this story about Bud
Light losing again and again and again
it's been over a month it was April 1st
that Dylan Mulvaney did this uh this
this Tick Tock and now May 10th
Anheuser-Busch is still spiraling
because of this
so keep it up I think I think we're
winning I I think that the the Bud Light
decision
right next to firing Tucker is probably
one of the dumbest business decisions
anybody has ever made well they tried
claiming it was a third party company
that did it and they're like oh we don't
know there's a third-party company that
did it yeah but apparently what uh there
was one writer for the Washington Post
who said
that Bud Light is a cash cow that's
never going to grow it is it is
basically generic at this point it is so
ubiquitous it's just synonymous with
beer Take the Money accept it but they
bring in some young VP of marketing he's
like I'm gonna grow this brand tries to
find a new demographic and then nukes it
into Oblivion she wanted to to shed the
Freddy image she said on one podcast
it's interesting the demographic that
they chose and I'm just talking about
the age 15 year olds I've heard uh Ian
talk about that a lot it's just like if
you look the the actual age group like
what exactly were they after there and
they have they said anything about that
teens you know they're not going to I
mean that's the thing it reminds me of
uh didn't cigarette companies get in
trouble at one point because they were
advertising like on children's toys or
whatever well no they had the Camel Joe
camels too nice yeah
and then they had to modify their
branding I think with Bud Light they
didn't think about the audience uh in
the consequences they only thought we
can capture young drinkers maybe they
aren't drinking maybe when they go to
drink they will start drinking Bud Light
they didn't think about the fact that
it's completely inappropriate for a lot
of reasons and they only put themselves
in their own ideology first I thought it
was funny this Washington Post writer
said the confusing thing about the
campaign was Dylan Mulvaney's foe Audrey
Hepburn act like caters to no one it's
like Dylan Mulvaney's audience are all
under 21 so they're not buying beer and
then the rest of the audience is over 50
and they're and they're drinking wine so
what was Bud Light thinking and then Bud
Light Of course like no no it was a
third party so now here's the best part
Yeah you mentioned I think it's it's up
to six gay bars yeah five or six in
Chicago have are boycotting
Anheuser-Busch outright because
Anheuser-Busch won't give them political
influence now think about that the right
just says leave us alone the left says
give us what we want or else
stop pandering to these people they're
gonna make your life miserable but you
know what we're winning so no not not to
play Devil's Advocate Advocate but uh
how was the rest of Anheuser-Busch doing
like because they have like
there's so many other products that like
globally Anheuser-Busch I think they
said it was like around one percent
decline yeah in general sales when this
but we're talking about American
cultural influence if Anheuser-Busch
says we were abandoning U.S markets with
Bud Light because it's a failed brand we
won yeah yeah I think we won already at
this point
no Clydesdale is going to save it yeah
that was such a toned effort yeah in a
dress wasn't that what Set uh Rogan off
was the Clydesdale the pandering yeah
but here's the story we have from uh
from Tim cast news Bud Light boycott is
spreading to other Anheuser-Busch Brands
company may be in a no win situation as
gay bars are ditching Anheuser-Busch
Beer see what's happened now is
because
these gay bars are upset with
Anheuser-Busch as a brand it's not even
about Bud Light to them it's about all
of of the brands they do so and
conservatives too right they were all
like I saw all these Graphics of like
don't drink Modelo here are the other
ones just so you know I mean because
it's like Biv or something like that
yeah
in Bev yeah
and it's a bomber because modelo's
actually pretty good yeah I think surge
is mourning that loss yep I am sad about
that
but it is interesting that it was a
boycott that was effective partially
because people were already aware of
what else was under the umbrella right
like if you boycotted I don't know uh a
shoe company right if they own four
other shoe companies you're not really
hurting them whereas people were able to
identify oh these are all but like wow
look look at this so we know that uh
Miller and Coors are way up like 20
right St Louis Business Journal says
Budweiser is down 11.4 that's not Bud
Light that's Budweiser Michelob Ultra
down 4.4 Bush light 1.8 and Natty light
5.2 so it is hitting their other brands
okay
so hey good good job everybody this uh
this warrants a round of drinks does
anybody have any uh oh wait it was funny
when Lance from the surface here he
brought a Bud Light tall boy yeah and he
waited till the after show I was like
bro why don't you crack that
on the show
like it was funny
you don't want everybody to see that in
a Bud Light you don't want anyone to
think that he was a famine or anything
like this how long do you think the
boycott will last I think they're done I
think I'm seeing people online there was
one story in Newsweek where a couple got
attacked and the they say was because
they were buying Bud Light and the
person like they got into a fight over
it or something like that I'm like
you're attacked at a liquor store yeah
because somebody started making fun of
them over buying Bud Light and then they
started yelling at each other but uh
alcohol was involved Bud Light brand is
everything and Bud Light is synonymous
with being a homosexual I am not saying
that to be mean or funny or derisive I
am saying that as a fact marketing
statement that if you because of Dylan
Mulvaney's notoriety and the backlash it
is now perceivably
associating you with being a homosexual
there was a video where a cast members
in the Book of Mormon crack beers in
like Times Square or something and say
hey Dylan like thank you so much but but
like they drink it and I'm like that was
the last thing Bud Light wanted to
happen because they're hammering the
nail into the coffin that if you drink
Bud Light you are likely an effeminate
homosexual man you're homosexual but
you're not enough of an ally that's why
the gay bars won't bring a buyer beer
but I I'm not sure that matters I mean
look if you're if you're some like 38
year old dude 40 year old dude at a ball
game do you want to be the one person
that was a viral video from Fenway Park
where nobody would buy Bud Light because
do you want to walk up to a chicken be
like hey want to Bud Light right and
she'll be like are you gay no no and
again I'm not saying to be the rest of
I'm saying the brand has Associated
itself with that because of the hyper
partisan nature of the sales of this
beer you will be perceived as being a
supporter of LGBT groups as left-wing or
as a gay man yourself if you're drinking
the beer there's a political Association
not with it I feel like the only real
save for them is to Simply Be Honest be
honest with what what the whole tactic
was and and maybe issue an apology but
it kind of feels like after you were
saying that it just made me feel like
well a tactic that you could potentially
imagine is now you could say that you're
discriminating and if you boycott and
discriminate against Bud Light you are
this you are homophobic you're
transphobic you're a white supremacist
they don't but light does not want that
because that just pushes them to one
market
it may now be the case that bud light's
only opportunity is to Pander to the
left but then they lose all their market
share because they've doubled down if
they came out right away and just said
we're really sorry about this campaign
we didn't realize it would be so
divisive please accept our apologies and
they just did that I'd imagine sales
would have would have recovered right
away but I'm telling you I've been in
these corporate Executive offices during
PR crises and I know exactly what these
people say they say listen the people
who buy your products are dumb as a box
of rocks they'll forget all about it
just shut your mouth PR 101 do not add
fuel to the fire and Bud Light Budweiser
azerboy said okay and they ignored it
and it festered and got worse then
someone said okay well we got to do
something now then they put out that
Clydesdale commercial which just made
everything worse they refused to
apologize and they don't realize the
people who drink their beer people these
days their their networked we're hooked
in we're not forgetting about this and
now it's gotten to the point where uh
someone mentioned on Twitter Babylon B
where to it said uh guys drinking Cosmos
at bar make fun of do drinking Bud Light
or something like that yeah that's the
perception of you when you go to a bar
and buy a Bud Light that you are like an
effeminate
man or gay or something yeah and guys
they don't want to they don't want to be
perceived that way especially when
they're trying to pick up chicks could
you imagine being in a bar and then
being like Oh there's some beautiful men
over there I'm not gonna get a Bud Light
give me an Old English give me a
Guinness
yeah I want to look strong you get a
Yingling and go hey ladies did you know
that Yingling is the oldest Brew in
America
and they're like oh wow that's so
impressive your knowledge is is
impressed me so much would you like to
join us and you're like that's right but
if you walk over with a Bud Light
they're going to be like I always wanted
a gay best friend and you're gonna be
like oh no no no no no no those are the
two choices
I am curious to see what happens with
the people working at Bud Light because
obviously if they have a downturn in
business I can only assume that layoffs
come I also imagine that the people who
actually work in their factories or
their breweries or whatever uh they
didn't get consulted for this moves and
now they're the live their livelihoods
are at risk because of you know one
Harvard grad uh marketing executive and
that seems pretty terrible to me yeah
we're gonna I was just gonna say like
what what officially happened with the
CEO
we're gonna go to Super Chat so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends if you really do like it because
boy they really don't like us head over
to timcast.com become a member and uh
let me let me take this opportunity to
use the negative press against us as a
Shameless call out and call to action if
you want to help Stick it to the Liars
in the corporate press who would be
smart our good name and a show that you
enjoy go to timcast.com click join us
become a member and then uh we win we
win they lose they Decay cease to exist
and then in 100 years we'll be writing
their obituary
and we're gonna have a members only show
coming up at 10 10 p.m we're gonna have
call-ins from the audience so you guys
can even call into the show let's read
voice of the people says Tim Google
Eugene Carroll jurora77 and read the
political article they tried to get rid
of that juror because he listens to you
Robert guvea covered that today you
should bring him on sometime spoke with
him before
we don't know who the juror is but he's
clearly not a supporter of trump or do
they mean Robert cavea that's really one
on right I know okay I'm saying as for
the this individual this juror we don't
know who he is and uh I look I'll I'll
say I don't know what evidence he saw in
trial that made him think Trump was
liable for this but it seems insane to
me I think the reality is it was
probably like uh what was that what was
that movie where all the jurors are in
the in the room and the one guys they're
like he's all 12 Angry Men 12 Angry Men
yeah it was like that the one guys and
they're like I don't know man I watched
Tim cast I'm a reasonable person I think
Trump's not liable and then they just
like
you feel like it had to be like a
technicality like like the law was
written in such a way that there was no
way to not convict like that they didn't
yeah yeah it had to be a really really
poorly written yeah he didn't get
convicted of sexual abuse convicted of
being liable for sex right right they
said if you think that Trump was
physically present then he's responsible
or something but you know what I'm just
gonna say this
there is no way
Donald Trump walked into the Bergdorf
without people being like Mr Trump oh
and people being like oh is this Donald
it's Donald Trump oh man wow it's like
dude so so I like to hang out at like
MGM National Harbor or Maryland Live or
whatever and every single time people
are going like hey Tim Poole man fist
bomb I'm like hey nice to meet you
what's your name Jim nice to meet you
man appreciate it Non-Stop and I am
nothing compared to I am I am an aunt I
am a zit on the ass of mosquito compared
to Donald Trump even in the 90s we're
talking about one of the most famous
people in the world with his name on a
building and you think he's gonna walk
into the burgdorf and nobody noticed
yeah nobody noticed he was there
incredible I liked his and I owned the
plaza
and he's walking around with no security
no no Donald Trump is even walking
around he's getting in cars he has
security detail people are opening the
door for him so when he walks into the
Bergdorf with like 10 staff members he's
like where's the lady oh man come this
way Steph follow me we're going to the
dressing room get out of here this is
insane right absolutely ridiculous story
all right Matt H says seriously Tim
check out humankind it's better than
civilization
I'll take a look
yeah I've heard that's good Goldilocks
production says Tim I gotta call you out
Nazi Germany was not fascist that was
Italy they were National Socialist
fascism National Socialist Communist and
Marxist all fall under left-wing
socialism learn history watch Tiki
history to learn more about this I
understand the I've read about uh the
national socialists policies so
basically there's many ways you can
bring it down national socialism was not
uh
people will call themselves things that
they're not antifa says that they're
anti-fascists when they're like
authoritarian Psychopaths so I guess you
can argue that antifa the original
anti-fascist action was the militant
wing of the Communist Party in Weimar
Germany so I get that but the thing
about National socialists fascists Etc
is that these were considered the right
because they were traditional
traditionalist and the Communists were
Ultra Progressive the Communists wanted
to purge history the the right the
various factions wanted to preserve
tradition and history and that was the
principle difference between two overtly
authoritarian factions which went on to
brutally murder millions of people what
are the Communist murder 100 million or
something 100 million years a lot of
people yeah that's crazy also Tik
history is cool it's a good page is it
oh is it Tiki history yeah Tik history
yeah
good information let's read some more
boosted yogisis from what I'm
understanding she filed the lawsuit the
day after it was signed into law
amazing wow nothing to see here don't
ask any questions totally legitimate
Bertman asks how come leftists aren't
boycotting CNN for platforming Trump uh
Bertman you're supposed to be a writer
over here at timcast and they are they
were there were people at CNN who was
there was a CNN commentator contractor
actually wrote a statement published
Twitter saying it is wrong that CNN is
doing this it should not be platforming
this man did they quit there was a bunch
of comments too yeah when it was first
announced there was tons of comments
from from Libs who were just pissed off
yep
all right where are we at with the super
jets
let's see what we got
because jackknife TV says they're going
to try to lead him on she is openly
pushing the subject to get him to dive
deeper as his reference to Trump talking
about January 6 and the election and
that's what I'm saying CNN when Trump
was like we got to talk about election
because our our brothers are terrible
right now and she's like well I want to
go back to January 6 because they want
the sound bites they want the
commercials they're doing Democrats a
favor in that I'm sure some democrat was
like can you get Trump to talk for even
a few minutes about January 6 and the
election because we are going to chop
that thing up a hundred ways and run ads
like crazy like don't worry don't worry
Kalyn Collins goes out there and the guy
in her ear saying ask him again not now
ask him again tell him no and go ask him
again and that's why she kept saying the
same things over and over again every
every time they have a debate that's
where the the moderators start from is a
list of questions that they have to ask
to so they can get the sound bite that
they want yeah and then they ask it in
the exact way that they need to look I
feel bad for that stay-at-home mom she
came in she asked a question a specific
question about the troops which I I
thought would have been an interesting
answer and to be fair Trump and sweet
sweet Caitlyn both ignored it Caitlyn
just introduced five other questions
bushdale says Trump hit it out of the
park he talks circles around that
sharing the stage with him and nailed
answering the crowd questions CNN
embarrassed themselves with this one I
completely agree I think he started a
little slow I was getting a little
frustrated but then he quickly just
swung it out of the park amazing amazing
when he was like well I'm not president
anymore that was that was so funny the
first big hit it was amazing it was
amazing
yeah I like what I like when he is
succinct and not not rattled when he was
getting rattled you could kind of tell
especially when they were talking about
the documents that was just too much
talking over one another right and
really that that's that's the
moderator's job to try and keep it from
getting that way right but I really like
the conversation about Ukraine and it
really made her look like dude she she
answered you or he answered you very
succinctly several ways and she kept
going back to it that's how you can see
she she's gotta try and pull something
out of it otherwise she's not doing her
job I like this
because Trump gives the answers I want
to hear
it's it's like is he perfect no of
course he's not nobody's going to be but
when he was talking about abortion and
she's like will you sign an abortion ban
politicians will be alive well you know
abortions are an interesting thing and I
think as an American we have to Trump
said it depends on what the deal is
bring the deal to me we'll negotiate
because we have negotiating power he's
like I got Roe v Wade overturned now
we'll bring the deal to the table we'll
see what we get and I'm like that's a
good answer it's like
it's absurd that they try and ask these
absolutist questions they know we'll do
the only thing that will happen is you
will lose support will you ban abortion
outright Donald Trump
could just be like well it's more
complicated than that probably to some
degree but not absolutely like you got
you gotta like the answer is not yes or
no and he even said he was like look
some people say six weeks some people
say eight weeks I don't know we'll see
and then she kept asking over and over
again what they're gonna do is they're
gonna clip it up and say Trump refused
to answer yeah well do you remember 20
in 2016 uh during the Republican debates
they kept asking him if he would accept
the results of the election
and they asked it over and over and over
again and he refused to respond yeah
um and that was again one of those
things where they were gonna they were
gonna throw that back at him and
the fishing all they do is fish right
Brandon hamson says as a sailor who has
been drunken we spend atrocious amounts
of money when we're half Seas over
thank goodness we're hearing from The
Source here we go now we know now we
know I think we're just being like the
sailors on leave right like right
compare that to all kinds of wild things
in high school in Singapore I saw a lot
of sailors only doing just that spending
absurd amount of money because they're
they're at Port you know yeah I was in
the Air Force we did the same yeah
totally but you guys aren't as gone for
as long as the the uh no Sailors we just
like the drink pretty much there
Sergeant Buck says Caitlin Collins is
debating Trump so much she may as well
announce she's running for president I
seriously
because a town hall isn't supposed to be
that no she's supposed to say what do
you think about X and then have them
answer and then and then once he's done
talking you can say so unlike the
election thing I would say Mr Mr
President you've stated X please explain
to the audience your views then Trump
talks then you can say yes but according
to this person your Administration you
were wrong about this how would you
respond to that
that's what a Town Hall's supposed to be
not no you're wrong you're wrong wrong
Trump like what are you debating him
yeah and then she kept doing it every
time like no I'm sorry that's not true
you're wrong you can't say that it's
like
you you you you're not here to debate
him on what is right or wrong he is here
to speak right it's crazy it's like live
fact checking is yeah it's ridiculous I
I am not a I'm not a trump fan but the
thing that I really appreciated from him
was the thing about Ukraine when she
kept saying who do you want to win it
was such an obvious bait thing and he he
actually he said it in the exact way
that you would want somebody to be like
it's not about winning it really is
about people not dying anymore
so immature I make CNN look so surface
level they're equating this to winning
it made their tactics very obvious and
it was it was such a virtue signal it's
like we need to be able to put you in a
camp so you need to answer this question
like I'm asking it not the not the way
you're asking it now that's why she kept
coming back to it yeah
desanctimonious
no it doesn't work
this yeah it's better this one I think
there's there has to be a better
nickname than that but just want this
he's just to Satan to Satan does Satan
might be a little too fast I honestly
think I think meatball Ron was the best
one yeah or just call him Ronnie like
make him sound like a little kid yeah
yeah I think there's a lot of ways along
with that yeah I'm not sure the
sanctimonious is my favorite Lil Ronnie
or meatball run meatball runs great I
mean I think Rhonda Sanders is the best
to Governor this country he's had in a
very very long time I think he's doing
amazing work in Florida
um and I think he'd be a great president
I'm leaning towards Trump at the current
moment and I think Trump just did an
excellent performance so I I've said
this a lot of times but do you think we
could maybe just not
like get into these two camps already
he's gotta be Trump descendants got to
be Trump like they said his VP also so
can we just be glad like Rana Sanchez
did lots of cool things let's not
eviscerate all of the Republicans
because you know you may support Trump
let's have lots of strong people in in
this side of the aisle I've said it a
lot on Twitter and I keep getting uh you
know attacked over it but like I don't
have a problem with Trump and I don't
have a problem with DeSantis and I'm not
sure why we have to have a problem with
one or one or the other and that's no it
needs to be Trump to stand this 2024.
it's it's the race to the bottom it's
the tactic it's like how do I make
myself look good well the tactic is
really smear the opponent yeah so that's
the race and I understand why Trump's
doing it see that's the thing is I
understand why Trump's doing it because
that's his job his job is to
you know get all the competition out of
the way
but I'm not sure why it's everyone on
Twitter's job to then also get rid of
anybody that that doesn't currently hold
the same position they do I think I
guess that's just the nature of Twitter
but they're used to regurgitating the
tactic yeah they don't come up with the
tactic they regurgitate the tactic
yeah
Raymond g Stanley Jr says this lady is
insufferable she really is she doesn't
have the same like I mean I I get that
they're trying and they do need someone
but you look at someone like Megan Kelly
and you know why she became an anchor
like she's got it do you look at Laura
Ingram and you're like I get it they
have they have punch like you watch them
and you're like that's a person with X
Factor Caitlyn constant have that it's
like dry droll and generic and whiny
yeah like that the biggest takeaway from
tonight for her was how whiny she was so
annoying no I feel that it's all right
it's not right no no she needed more
Poise yeah she was she wasn't poised you
could tell even though she had like good
posture and she didn't really like
cringe her face too much you could tell
yeah she got upstage
it's not about being upstage I mean
you're not supposed to be there too
upstage or right but she has no presence
it's like it's like she was an inverse
presence like sucking energy instead of
exuding energy totally I think this is
something that you'll hear tomorrow a
lot which is that oh the right is
attacking her for pushing back on Trump
and girls have such a hard time because
when they assert themselves or said it
says people say they're bossy and I
think it's important to note that like
she didn't perform well it's not about
the fact that she's female it's the fact
about the fact that she did not moderate
this conversation she really tried to
argue her points and in fact if she did
not Advance this experience for anyone
including the network she's supposed to
represent well it was her conversation
yeah yeah she wasn't advancing anyone
else's conversation except and she
didn't win anything she made herself and
therefore CNN looked bad yeah
what do we got here two snlorum says not
making every single liberal who fled a
city did mail-in voting to cast a vote
and voted locally in the place they fled
to a non I I this is kind of sentence
fragmenting I'm not sure what what
they're saying a non-voting felon for
life is the same same thing as too big
to fail argument because it would
obliterate the Democratic Party
they responding to something but I can't
tell what it was yeah it's yeah okay I
was trying to read it sorry man I
appreciate it but um
a non-voting felon for life is the same
exact thing as a too big to fail
argument you're implying that if we take
away a felon's right to vote Democrats
lose
that's that's what I can figure out from
that I'm not sure
yeah I don't know that's that's
interestingly worded
yeah uh dansky says Tim I think you're
confusing the Texas shooter with a juror
read four episodes I am not
um in the in the in the court documents
they say he watched three or four
episodes and the shooter posted four
clips from one episode so that guy only
watched one episode and uh the media
just lies you know whatever
sir alexanderfel says they want to give
Tucker Carlson your time slot why he's
this is the crazy thing right like I go
on Joe Rogan's show and he and he's
talking about ivermect and I'm like I
disagree I don't think it does anything
and they're like Tim Poole is the poster
boy forever I've ever met and I'm like
what are you talking about it's the
weirdest thing that they're like
desperate they're like please Tim please
please be right wing and I'm like I just
disagree with that I just don't
understand and then here I am using the
New York Times as a source and they're
like he must be far right it's just dude
I mean keep doing that you're
discrediting yourselves if you're I'll
take the freebies if you're a right wing
then your Fox's problem right you're
stealing Fox's audience but if you are
moderate and you're drawing from both
places then you are everybody's problem
and that's what they don't want well
that's why they're going after me now
because they're like our audience will
like an urban liberal New Yorker in the
Bronx will watch Tim cast
yeah it's like we got it we gotta stop
that you cannot take The Young Turks
audience from them well yeah you're
right don't do it you're right because
they've already lost it
and Matt Gates was there he was saying
he'd come out here he'd done the show
and then we went to Congress and he was
like I was amazed by how many truck
drivers or waitresses or just working
people were like oh I saw you on Tim
Poole that was awesome man like I think
people underestimate uh podcasting in
general I don't think they really
understand or know how to measure and
compare to like these mainstream
established platforms but especially the
work that you've done it's it's Unique
in a way that they are not sure what to
do so they'd rather just crushing New
York Times I don't even know what the
show is yeah they said the culture War
like that thing we launched two months
ago and there's like what do we have 11
episodes literally 11 episodes 11
episodes in 11 episodes you have
corrupted a jury
the thing like we talk about conspiracy
theories we've never talked about
conspiracies the Legacy Media doesn't
understand any of the New Media at all
no uh I mean they don't it's clear from
the tactics that they take that they
don't understand you know Joe Rogan they
don't understand Tim Poole they don't
understand
whoever like
they are completely living 20 years in
the past and they're getting their own
cult they're getting killed too I mean
uh the ratings or the the watches for
this show
will
take out pretty much any of CNN's like
daily stuff oh yeah no question they
don't even they don't even hit they
barely hit five figures in the key demo
right well any any animal that's dying
lashes out for the last Bastion of
control and really what what the Legacy
Media is seeing is that this new media
and alternative media is really stepping
up so they need to try and exercise some
control over it by placing people in
certain camps and them controlling The
Narrative of what those camps mean and I
think you know it's it sounds trite to
say it but the 2024 election is likely
going to be the most important one of
all time this is a very seemingly
pivotal time in history so it makes
sense to like okay who has sway who has
influence
control the boxes that you can put them
in and that way the Legacy Media that
feels like they're dying has a little
bit of control left but does it really
matter since the robots are going to
kill us anyway they're not they're not
going to it's now so Terminators I
haven't seen that movie yet so I don't
know the Terminator is going to knock on
your door and then the people are going
to be like it's the Terminator it's come
to get us and he's gonna clean your
house and he's going to plug into your
brain and then give you Untold euphoric
pleasures and put you into the metaverse
where you experience all the great
things and you never want to leave like
what was it in uh in Star Trek
generations was it the the Nexus what do
you call it it was yeah but I've never
seen that movie because I'm not a Star
Trek person right where it's like so
basically there's this like dimensional
Rift or something and when you're in it
you experience
ultimate happiness William Shatner has a
family yeah and he's chopping wood in
the forest and he doesn't want to leave
and Picard but I'm not a nerd to leave
you have to leave this he's speculating
I don't know just speculating I I saw
the cliff notes to the movie I didn't
actually watch it well that's kind of
like SoMo we were talking about before
so much yeah what was that 1984.
yeah yeah so like being happy with your
servitude bro they're gonna equilibrium
the best movie ever made the first thing
I think happens is they go to people who
lose loved ones and they say just plug
in and we've taken the social media of
your loved one and create an AI version
of them you can talk to them and ask
them questions and they're not going to
want to leave it's called the replica
have you seen that replica replica oh
the dating app well yeah they tried
taking dating away from it because dudes
were you know well yeah and then and
then some people were let down because
they kind of pulled back because it was
getting a little too hot and heavy for
them but it actually started the the the
woman who launched it it was because she
lost her best friend or something like
that so she made a clone so she could
cope with the loss uh you know so like
that's where it started and then it
started turning into like a dating do
you think that's coping like if you lose
someone and you make a clone of them do
you think you're actually grieving or
anything avoiding grief you know like
that that's a very interesting nuanced
question because I would say is
meditating coping is praying coping is
like any anything from alcohol to
cannabis to long walks on the beach
coping but if you lose someone and they
can't talk to you anymore so you make a
version of life where they can talk to
you are you actually letting that person
go are you grieving the loss and
accepting that they are gone yeah I
don't think there's a clear answer to
that because in in a sense I know many
people who have like lost a loved one
and they still speak with them in some
way so this is externalizing it in the
same way that writing is externalizing
your mind onto the outside world so I
don't know I don't know how to fully
answer that I do go to timcast.com and
become a member for all of the answers
to the universe what a segue for that we
can give you so go to timcast.com become
a member thanks for hanging out smash
that like button subscribe to the show
share the show with all your friends
we're gonna have that members only
uncensored show come coming up in about
10 minutes we've got a lot more to talk
about you can find us at timcast IRL
basically everywhere you can follow me
personally at timcast Carpe dantum do
you want to shout anything out uh Dom
Luker
that was a good shout out yeah all right
and and uh Carpe docked him on Twitter
okay great
yeah uh well I'll just say go to Ben
josephstewart.com check out all the
content that I make go to my YouTube
page which which is YouTube
uh.com backslash Ben Joseph Stewart and
you'll see all the mini docs that I've
been making on things like modern day
Malik and where AI is headed and why I
seem to be an optimist on all of it and
we got a documentary that we're
launching very soon as well game of
money it's kind of a play on Game of
Thrones so uh yeah and then a lot more
to come after that we got a bunch of
cool projects potentially so
transhumanism is going to be an awesome
that's the one I want to do the most but
this banking one I think is is
particularly relevant we got lucky with
that it's timely yeah yeah right that'll
be awesome I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm
a writer for timcast.com you should
follow at 10cast news on Twitter and
Instagram if you want to follow me
personally you can find me on Instagram
at Hannah B and on Twitter at HC brimlow
thanks so much guys and I am at
surge.com uh are you with me on Twitter
as always I will be in the chat for this
video if you have any questions so
please send my way all right everybody
we will see you in about 10 minutes on
the front page of timcast.com for the
uncensored members only show thanks for
hanging out